[Aplausos]
esta es una historia de amor
es una historia que es tan antigua como
la vida lo ha permitido y en constante
construcción sin embargo esta noche les
compartiremos un pequeño fragmento de
esta historia si acaso una mirada fugaz
para ello voy a tener que contextualizar
un poco y volver la mirada a unos años
atrás cuando un chico y una chica se
encuentran y a pocos días de haberse
conocido deciden compartir su vida
después de muchas aventuras idas y
vueltas encuentros y desencuentros de
ser dos pasar a ser tres nos vamos a
encontrar
en este momento
la lluvia tiene algo que no sabemos bien
por qué pero generalmente nos pone
reflexivos nos invita a la introspección
y recuerdo de esa tarde era una de esas
estábamos en casa tranquilamente
disfrutando de unos mates
y en una me percaté a lo era mi hijo
estaba enchufadísimo con la tablet
viendo sus dibujitos animados sus
jueguitos y en ese momento comenzaron a
fluir por mi cabeza un montón de
recuerdos de la infancia de como
disfrutábamos las tardes lluviosas en la
cooperativa la vida del campito juego de
fútbol el embarrarnos en la cuneta el el
andar y en ese mismo momento sin
pensarlo de repente le mandé a apagar la
tablet y le di fiscal vámonos que nos
vamos a jugar bajo la lluvia me miró
como diciendo estás loco no pero está
salió corriendo más rápido que ligero y
en un segundo ya estaba en la puerta
como teniendo miedo a que me arrepienta
y bueno salimos pasamos una tarde súper
divertida diferente a otras tardes de
lluvia donde estuvimos haciendo carreras
de barquitos saltando en los charcos de
agua y simplemente disfrutando de la
lluvia en la cara
ya más tranquilos después estando
adentro ya relajados comenzó otra lluvia
pero esta era la lluvia de preguntas y
cal
había comenzado a preguntarse y a
preguntarnos el agua que caiga de la
lluvia de dónde venía esa agua que
corría que se llevaba en los barquitos
con los que jugábamos a dónde iban
días después estábamos en el centro de
educación ambiental lugar donde
trabajamos maurillo y ese día y carl nos
había acompañado y bueno cada quien
estaba como inmerso en sus actividades y
de repente me di cuenta que carl
conversaba y conversaba con alguien y me
dio curiosidad pues soy su mamá
y fui hasta la entrada me percaté que
había interceptado a una pareja de
veteranos que entraban en el centro y
que voluntariamente les ofreció hacerles
un recorrido entonces me dio más
curiosidad fui hasta acercarme escuchar
y me percaté que ya los había llevado al
árbol de mora a la casita de lagarto
bueno a todos los lugares que él
consideraba que eran dignos de conocerse
del lugar y se dirigían a los baños
bueno y fui hasta allá y escuché de
repente que uno de los veteranos le dijo
a ical
pero estos baños no tienen agua y qué es
eso que tienen en ese cachito
y cal con una naturalidad les contestó
lo que pasa es que estos son unos baños
secos y los baños secos no usan agua los
baños secos cuidan el agua que es la
misma que cae cuando llueve y la que con
mi papá y yo salimos a jugar y hacemos
carreras de barquitos en la vereda
lo tenía claro yo me quedé realmente
maravillada
que también reflexiva qué es lo que
había sucedido qué fue lo que pasó
nuestro hijo de cinco años había logrado
hacer una conexión un vínculo con esta
tarde de lluvia en compañía de su padre
y con con desde su corazón de niño había
encontrado un motivo genuino para querer
cuidar el agua y para usar los baños
secos
por acá estoy acá en la foto bueno tengo
que confesarles que tiempo después esta
anécdota se convirtió en una charla de
sobremesa bastante larga entre maurizio
donde discutíamos temáticas dije pues
del quehacer del educador socioambiental
en la discusión estuvimos reflexionando
sobre diferentes prácticas educativas
que generalmente hemos normalizado y
estamos acostumbrados a ver en
diferentes medios de comunicaciones
redes sociales instituciones educativas
y seguramente imágenes como esta la vez
hemos visto más de una vez y siempre
vienen acompañadas de datos graves datos
catastróficos que nos presentan la
desertificación a nivel mundial la
pérdida de biodiversidad la extinción
masiva de especies la contaminación de
nuestros alimentos por los agroquímicos
y el impacto en nuestra salud es cierto
son todos temas reales que nos preocupan
y nos deben de ocupar y urge sin lugar a
dudas crear un sistema social político y
económico distinto al que tenemos
actualmente que es el que nos trajo
hasta este punto
hoy la reflexión va por otro lado lo que
nos queremos plantear y queremos que
entre todos lo hagamos es si este tipo
de campaña que buscan la sensibilización
la concientización son las adecuadas
para nuestros niños y niñas david su
suave el hace unos años acuñó el término
eco fobia que ni más ni menos es el
miedo y la apatía por la naturaleza cómo
se llega a ese punto se llega mediante
la repetición constante de este tipo de
campañas
que nos presentan a la naturaleza desde
un punto de vista negativo y
catastrófico
entonces logra justamente el objetivo
contrario para el cual en teoría fue
pensado
en el tiempo que tenemos trabajando en
temáticas ambientales muchas personas se
han interesado por el trabajo que
hacemos y nos han preguntado cosas así
como bueno cuéntame cómo es ese lugar
donde trabajan y casi siempre empiezo
diciéndoles bueno es un centro de
educación ambiental para niños esta
asociación es muy frecuente por lo cual
también hemos reflexionado
preguntándonos porque pensamos que la
educación ambiental es exclusivamente
para niños
detrás de esto de esa asociación existe
una normalización en la sociedad que
trata de ver las problemáticas
ambientales que serán que éstas van a
ser resueltas en un futuro y por lo
tanto es responsabilidad de las
generaciones futuras hacerse cargo de
estos problemas o sea serán ellos quien
den solución y quiénes son esas
generaciones futuras pues los niños y
las niñas
sin darnos cuenta estamos depositando
sobre sus hombros una mochila muy pesada
una mochila que ellos no pueden
gestionar ni deben por su edad de
hacerlo
hay que freire es una psicóloga y
pedagoga que nosotros tomamos como
referencia por su trabajo ella menciona
que es durante los primeros años de vida
de los niños y niñas que ellos
establecen los vínculos emocionales no
solamente con su madre su padre o sus
tíos o los seres queridos que estén
alrededor sino con todo el entorno
natural
también menciona que es aproximadamente
a la edad de los 11 años cuando se
sugiere empezar a abordar las temáticas
ambientales desde el visto desde el
punto de vista del problema siempre y
cuando estos problemas sean locales y el
niño los haya percibido desde un ámbito
cotidiano es decir que pueda generar
también soluciones que puedan
reflexionar los y que pueda accionar que
pueda hacer algo al respecto
entonces esta es una invitación es una
invitación a tomar la responsabilidad en
el presente a darnos cuenta que en el
presente los adultos somos nosotros y
los niños y niñas son niños y niñas
que si algo hemos de hacer por
solucionar todas estas catástrofes que
vienen como en esas publicidades que nos
dan pues tiene que ser a partir del día
de hoy
con nuestro ejemplo abandonemos el
confort abandonemos esas ganas de no de
lavarnos las manos y no hacer nada que
se esconden detrás del discurso de las
futuras generaciones
y bueno para ello también es necesario
crear ser más empáticos y darnos cuenta
cómo estamos como adultos
seguramente todos aquí presente
conocemos la locación de esta fotografía
y disculpen si alguno salió despeinado
en la foto algún domingo distraído lo
agarramos por allí trajimos la foto está
por qué
y el cómo habitamos nuestros espacios
naturales demuestra y refleja de cierta
manera que están conectados
desconectadas desconectados y estamos
con la naturaleza no en la imagen
podremos sacar nuestras propias
conclusiones cada uno cuando lo quiera
desear
de cómo habitamos él es uno de los
espacios naturales más grandes y lindos
que tenemos en la ciudad
ahora como indira contaba nosotros
adultos que debemos generar y propiciar
ese desarrollo y ese vínculo entre el
niño la niña y la naturaleza debemos
primero volver a conectarnos y recuperar
ese vínculo nosotros como adultos no
podemos contagiar algo que nosotros no
somos entonces
lo podemos hacer de mucha manera y
seguramente si cada uno de nosotros
pensamos y recordamos momentos de
nuestra infancia seguramente
encontraremos algún momento de felicidad
de alegría
y si nos ponemos a analizarlo
seguramente este la naturaleza vinculada
más allá aún más acá
y se preguntarán entonces como adultos
qué podemos hacer en el cotidiano en
nuestra vida cotidiana para poder seguir
propiciando que los niños estén las
niñas y los niños estén vinculados a la
naturaleza
bueno aquí hay varias recomendaciones
que también hay que mencionar una de
ellas tiene que ver con fomentar el
juego libre y qué es esto del juego
libre es algo muy sencillo que tiene que
ver con que los niños y las niñas puedan
reunirse y jugar sin intervención de los
adultos que ellos pongan las reglas que
decidan qué juegos quieran jugar y
cuáles no qué creen imaginen nuevos
juegos
y que puedan ellos decidir sobre sobre
eso que están jugando
otra de las cosas que podemos hacer es
fomentar que existan espacios donde los
niños puedan tocar oler sentir que
puedan ensuciarse hay un terror en la
actualidad a ensuciarse de los niños
agarran un poco de barro y dicen ay qué
asco como si fuera lo más terrible del
mundo algo está pasando y nosotros
podemos hacer que ellos vuelvan a querer
tener ese contacto sin duda si lo
logramos que podemos
pues lograremos tener muchos beneficios
no solamente a nivel intelectual y a
nivel individual sino también colectivo
en generar este vínculo y el
reconectarnos con la naturaleza
seguramente es una pieza clave en el
desarrollo del ser humano y sobre todo
en el desarrollo de los niños y niñas
porque va a ser clave en el desarrollo
psicosocial psicomotriz cognitivo en el
aparato en el sistema perdón
inmunológico by vamos a tener niños más
creativos con mayor imaginación y sobre
todo niños más empáticos con la vida o
sea con nuestros padres
y en fin somos naturaleza como especie
surgimos del mundo natural volvernos a
conectar sin lugar a dudas nos trae
beneficios a todos
recuerdan que al inicio les dije que
esta era una historia de amor
bueno propiciemos que nuestras niñas y
niños puedan amar la vida amar la tierra
antes de pedirles que la salven gracias
ellos